marriage has always seemed a little bit
problematic to me the idea that a
government gets to decide whether or not
you are married according to a given set
of laws or a religious authority gets to
do so I was thinking about this as I was
in the process of getting married and
thinking about the fact that honestly as
much as that paperwork would matter to
the government it wouldn't really matter
much to me or to my future wife I wanted
to find a way to get married that was
deeper that was more Universal than
whatever sort of legal framework could
be thrown my way by the United States
government
I wanted to instead be married by a law
of nature that is possible today perhaps
for the first time because of advances
in quantum physics you wouldn't think it
quantum physics tends to be either
highly theoretical or a system that is
used for instance in cryptography
however quantum entanglement one of the
essential systems that comes out of
quantum mechanics is one that has the
potential I believe to serve as a way in
which marriage can be based on a truly
universal foundation quantum
entanglement involves two or more
particles becoming effectively one in
the same even if they are separated
across the universe from each other when
they are entangled anything that happens
to one instantaneously happens to the
other as if it had been done to the
second particle that quality seems
an awful lot like what marriage is about
this way in which you can lead separate
lives and yet you still are somehow
bound and whatever comes away of one
person in a relationship also applies to
the other so I said about building an
apparatus that would allow my wife and I
and others as well to become entangled
to become married in a way that no
governmental authority no religious
authority could say that that it was not
allowed that it was inappropriate that
gay marriage for instance would not be
an issue that a government could
regulate that any sort of relationship
at all if it was meaningful to you could
become fully manifest as an entangled
relationship as a marriage at the basis
of all reality the apparatus was very
simple I used a special sort of crystal
which was able to take sunlight photons
and to bombard two people standing below
the apparatus with those photons in a
way that they themselves became
entangled by the entanglement of the
photons so that while it would not
necessarily be all of them while it
would not necessarily withstand all time
and space they could partake in this
process of entanglement and they could
then take away from it what they wanted
to take away that is to say that any
quantum system is extremely delicate
entanglement is no exception any
measurement that you make has the effect
of collapsing the system in other words
two particles that are entangled if you
check to see if they are entangled will
become disentangled and so likewise two
people who are
married by the process of quantum
entanglement should they question that
bond and start to interrogate it will
become disentangled as well so in a
sense the entanglement operates both
literally and metaphorically literally
because I'm using real equipment that is
used for entanglement for purposes of
encryption for instance to entangle
people and people are becoming genuinely
entangled by that process but it is also
I think more importantly the knowledge
that that process has taken place and
the way in which that makes those people
behave that is what makes for an
entanglement so special as a form of
marriage the fact that it really has to
be taken on faith ultimately because the
quantum mechanics demands it and
relationships are that way too
relationships are delicate in the sense
that quantum systems are so I think that
we can actually learn from subatomic
particles how to behave toward each
other in a caring long-term relationship
I think that the metaphor that is
inherent in the language and in the
common understanding of a quantum
process can be something that we can
apply quite literally and highly
productively in our everyday lives
you might say that metaphors are just
metaphors you know like a poem how
important can it be how seriously can
you take something that was meant for
the enjoyment that you might get reading
a book to what extent can you really
make use of it I think that metaphor
actually is something that can be used
incredibly productively
by taking it literally not by taking it
literally and leaving it at that
but recognizing the metaphor for what it
is and finding what happens if you apply
it literally in your life so that in the
case of quantum physics because quantum
physics is so weird because quantum
particles behave in ways that are so
totally foreign to the way in which we
live to our experience of the world much
of the discussion of quantum physics
happens metaphorically and the metaphors
can be mined I think and can be applied
I believe in ways that lead through
their literal application to different
ways in which we can relate to each
other in the world that is to say that
quantum particles relate to each other
in ways that are entirely different from
those with which we are familiar from
those with which we relate with each
other on an everyday basis the way in
which we relate to each other on an
everyday basis doesn't always work so
well we fight we have problems
communicating we go to war so might it
be possible taking the quantum realm the
metaphors that are used to explain how
quantum particles interact and applying
those metaphors literally in our lives
that we may realign the way in which we
live that makes us somehow unlike how we
were before and that repositioning while
it need not be absolute or permanent at
least can be something that we can try
out can be another way in which we can
consider our relationship with others
and can through that process give us
more perspec
- on the myriad possibilities as far as
a society where there are seven billion
of us for how that society can interact
and interrelate